foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is James page at the ftth council
meeting in Madrid I'm joined by Berwick
chairman Costas marcellos Costas thank
you for joining us one of the key issues
being talked about today is the ftth's
council's vision of a gigabit future in
Europe
um I wonder where you think we are with
that and what we else we need to do to
be taking that Vision forward oh thank
you James well indeed the vision for
gigabit connectivity is obviously a call
for FDD AIDS fiber networks deployment
acceleration
fiber fiber networks is obviously the
technology that is offers more many
advantages compared to other
Technologies Access Network Technologies
faster speeds lower latencies better
cost per speed ratio reliability
scalability but also its technology
proven in the field
secure and with a very clear roadmap for
the future towards 25 even 50 gigabits
per second but even more importantly
it's to some extent it's a technology
that reduces energy dissipation of
networks and contributes to CO2
emissions reduction so I believe fiber
networks are the technology that can
combine digital transformation and green
transition so these twin objectives that
should be our objective towards digital
transformation and sustainability
fantastic it's a it's a really exciting
Vision but of course everything like
that costs money
um how is the investment situation where
is the money going to come from to drive
that forward well indeed this is this
has been the discussion for a few months
now
with regards to Investments European
Union has defined some very ambitious
objectives with regards to ICT but also
with regards to connectivity
specifically so by 2030 we we want to
have one gigabit per second
connections for all users in Europe also
covered as 100 by Wireless technology
equivalent to 5G for all the European
population and at the same time we want
to become a climate neutral continent
region by 2050. so deployed network
deployments is capital intensive for
sure we all know that and it seems that
we Face some investment silences
if there are several reports indicating
this if we go back to 2020 the European
commission's report on saving Europe's
digital future indicates uh an
investment gap of 65 billion for digital
infrastructure per year when the the
capex invested by all operators in
Europe was 45 billion even in the
exploratory consultation of the European
commission which is currently in
progress there are some there are some
data indicating that we might need
170 to 180 billion euros to reach this
connectivity objectives so this is
indeed a big Challenge and we need
Regulatory and policy action to address
this well exactly I mean I suppose you
often quite hear from the business in
the investor community that they need
that right secure regulatory environment
in order to feel confident to investor
what can what can Europeans Europe's
regulators and and Beric do to to create
that that investment environment well I
I think as a stable predictable
regulatory environment is key to attract
Investments
um we need to address two main
directions one is to create an
environment that can attract investment
and on the other hand we need to also
address the demand side so what we want
to do we want to deploy networks that
are financially sustainable in the long
term so safe for Investments but on the
other hand we want them to be
economically accessible by by the
citizens so we want to build networks to
be used by the citizens if we focus
specifically on fdt8 fiber to the home
networks I would say that key priority
should be the copper switch off process
so we need to have simply transparent
procedures to switch off the Legacy
Network so that this depreciated network
does not unfairly compete with ftd8 this
is One Direction second we need to
consider Open Access networks so that
there is a fair
fair term access possibility for
retailers to ftth network infrastructure
we don't want to duplicate multiple
times
networks in some regions which have
commercial interests but we have no
network in some less commercially
interesting regions and of course I
believe key key challenge with regards
to ftt AIDS
is that we need to start considering the
in-building cabling for fiber and not
and stop considering homes passed so
it's it's quite different we focus on
bringing fiber in the entrance of the
building but not inside the building and
there we need to do more
really really interesting thank you for
giving us that Insight
um what's your world we've got you here
what's your personal opinion if if I can
ask it on on the future of electronic
communications networks presumably you
have to be an optimist
well this is again a topic of discussion
these days
um in the end of February European
commission launched an exploratory
consultation on the future of
connectivity and infrastructures in
Europe so if we look at the future of
connectivity and networks I think we
need to consider the the services of the
future what kind of services will be
offered over this over these networks
for example we talk a lot about
autonomous driving
a very hot application
what are the requirements to have this
service is it only faster networks maybe
not we want to if we have if we consider
autonomous cars we realize that this car
should be connected 90 percent of their
roots in the network and this means we
need Network to be predictable
and this service to be continuous if we
consider for example telemedicine or
e-health applications is it only higher
speeds that we need no again we need
predictable networks with continuity but
at the same time reliability and
resiliency so we need multiple data
paths between the doctor and and the
patient so
to to to to conclude I would say that we
don't only need high speeds we need also
quality of service in other
with regards to other characteristics of
the networks and this means that we
might have to reconsider uh the best
effort type of networks we have today
maybe best effort is good for some
applications but for some specialized
applications is not good enough and of
course this does not mean that in the
future how our Network should not be
open and neutral but we need to realize
that part of the network will have to be
quality of service oriented and not only
best effort
really really interesting
um and would love to have some more time
to to talk to you or maybe we'll get you
back for more because that was um a lot
of ground covered in a short space but
um because it's fantastic
um to talk to you thank you for helping
to explain some of that I hope you have
a great conference thank you James
foreign foreign
[Applause]
[Music]